wreckit-ralph - also known as Ralph
breaks the Internet has a new trailer
released by Disney this week showing
Ralph and vanellope 's new adventures as
they surf the worldwide web we're going
through tubes this trailer is full of
little Easter eggs and references that
are pretty great let's break down this
trailer and point out all these
miserable details gonna run through
quickly here we go okay first this shot
of lit wax arcade tells us that the
second movie takes place six years after
the first the sign says happy 11th
birthday Suzie Suzie with a V which is a
callback to the sign in the first movie
when it said happy 5th birthday Suzie
Suzie with the V must really love this
arcade she comes here every year
alright also once we go inside of the
arcade there's a bunch of details the
arcade games include pac-man Space
Invaders Virtua cop also the made for
the movie ones sugar rush and fix-it
Felix jr. that wreck Ralph is in simpler
better times room the box for this guy's
new Wi-Fi router says 800 or 8000
percent faster ish and the router sits
atop a Dragon's Lair video game that was
in stranger things season 2 if remember
inside lit wax office you can see
collectible Yoda in Chewbacca plates and
this computer looks like that 90s era
iMac with the you know we remember with
the color body and the USB Wi-Fi adapter
and on the desktop for that computer one
of the file says letter to Nana which is
a callback to the first movie when
Litwack made a joke about his Nana had
gone cuckoo and had to be taken out to
pasture inside the Internet our ton of
Easter eggs referencing different
websites just to list the ones we
spotted quickly there's Alison e Hulu
Cisco YouTube TripAdvisor IMDB National
Geographic eBay there also a few parody
sites like the daily roast for The Daily
Beast smashable for Mashable expect you
for Expedia and Buzz food for BuzzFeed
and one of the things being auctioned
off at eBay this is fun is the genies
lamp from Aladdin notice how it's going
for 35 bucks that's a probably and out
of the joke house lamp was like
considered worthless at the beginning of
Aladdin they're also cameos from Sir
protector and Cubert those are
characters in the first movie and
various internet jokes about pop-up ads
and clickbait headlines and if you look
closely the background there's a pretty
dirty joke with a help desk providing
services for unzipped services and
history clearance feel like I'd be at
that all the time
and this any bit with a pancake
milkshake game it's pretty pretty great
it's very reminiscent of the exploding
man gag and Monty Python's the meaning
of life I love it and a lot of people
have actually pointed out that the
little girl playing this game in the
back of her car on the iPad is the same
character design as baby Moana now it
could be a coincidence but this movie
was animated and written by the same
exact team that did Moana so it's
probably an intentional easter egg game
if it screws in the continuity what do
you guys think record Ralph to will
succeed when it comes to internet humor
where things like maybe the emoji movie
already play a one when it comes to
Easter eggs and the 80s called yeah and
all that kind of stuff but wreck-it
Ralph I mean it was before ready play
one so I think it's really timely did it
really well the first time the humor was
on point well record Ralph I really did
enjoy the first one and I was amazed at
how many different like references they
were able to fit in a movie I am excited
to see this hopefully that like some of
those internet humor things are spanked
toned down and they they keep it more
about like yeah well let us know what
you're most excited about for Ralph
breaks the internet wreck-it Ralph to
comment down below and hit us up on
Twitter and as a reminder to subscribe
to new rock stars for more trailer
breakdowns videos about Pixar movies
like The Incredibles and Coco in a
really weird one about cars go check out
thanks everybody